Do you have trouble sleeping?
Struggling to fall asleep at night
Waking up easily in the middle of the night
or waking up too early in the morning
But what if I told you that
a specific blend of certain scents
could help treat insomnia
We also want to share a little tip with you
How you can adjust these scents
based on what you need
Learn how to use them to create a recipe
that’s perfect for your family
The reason we're doing this episode is that
we want you to really apply this theory
not just randomly come up with a perfect recipe of herbal teas
Think of something salty, sour, and bitter
How about Pineapple with bitter melon soup? Does this sound good?
Today, I’m glad to have my friend
Dr. Xiao
here to talk about an interesting topic
In traditional Chinese medicine
Beyond just the effects of it
there's a deeper underlying logic
that makes them effective
I guarantee that you’ve never heard
this kind of information anywhere else
Come along with us till the end of this episode
I assure you'll see insomnia in a whole new light.
Alright, let's welcome Dr. Xiao
Hey guys
I’m Dr. Xiao
it's been a while
To be honest
talking about insomnia
and preparing for this topic
has made me realize just how challenging it really is
Insomnia feels like a classic hit song
from pop music
that’s been covered by many experts
If you search 'insomnia Chinese medicine' online
you’ll find hundreds of videos
So in this episode
we want to take on the challenge of
standing out
from those hundreds
and offer a perspective you’ve never heard before
that can actually make a difference for you
So, besides tune in to my feelings
at midnight
what else can we do?
(Music playing)
It’s just too catchy
I’ll like to show you about sour, bitter, sweet, pungent, and salty
Which you often hear about
the five basic flavors
how they're actually used in clinical trial
We'll discuss how you can use these flavors to create a recipe
that's good for your family
Not just in making herbal teas
but also in improving our medical skills
based on these principles with other practitioners
So it seems like
we're going to dive into something
that doesn’t come up often
something I used to think was unimportant back then
like sour, bitter, sweet, pungent, and salty
or even wood, fire, earth, metal, and water
I must say, as a Traditional Chinese physician who passed the exams
still don’t have a clear idea of how to use it in daily life
What makes this so important?
Dr.Ming just mentioned something
that brings back memories for both of us
since we were classmates
One thing we both remember is that
whenever you open any traditional Chinese medicine books
the first thing you'll see is a description of the herb's flavor and flavor nature
Let’s say, Ephedra
You can definitely find this information in any books
or even just by
Google it
you’ll see it’s been described as bitter, spicy, and warm
It's the kind of thing we usually struggle to remember
even though it comes up in exams
But beyond that
I’ve recently realized
how much these insights
actually impact its effectiveness in treatment
Yeah, we can’t remember it is because
we don't know how to use scents as a guide in clinical trail
Thanks to the ancients that got nothing better to do
As we just mentioned
ephedra: dispersing lung-Qi, anti-asthmatic, and diaphoretic
but I don’t really get
I mean warm helps
but what does the bitter and spicy aspects do
I genially have no idea
It’s almost like
alchemist’s code
that I always thought was just a myth
So, here’s a groundbreaking idea
to share with you
Scents
actually play a key role
in regulating the functions of your organs
Think of it like the gas pedal, brake, and clutch
they can either boost, inhibit, or balance how your organs functions
Dr. Xiao
I feel like this topic
is a vast ocean of information
that really takes time to dive into
Yeah, so there’s something I've been working on
an online course
specifically about how scents can help balance organ function based on this theory
We might not be able to cover
the whole idea here
but we can give you a glimpse of
how this powerful
and useful perspective
could have an impact
on your sleep issues
It's like
building on our existing knowledge
with new insights
but we won't dive into it today
If you're interested
please check out Dr. Xiao's online course
So today we’ll be focusing on this topic
Which is sleep
If we’re talking about using flavors like sour, bitter, sweet, spicy, and salty
to improve sleep
What’s the mindset behind that?
Here’s the takeaway in short
the core of this video
it’s that
For better sleep, we need three flavors
First is salty
second is bitter
and the last one is sour
Any combination
of these three flavors
might help with sleep
Sour, bitter, salty, and then adjusting sleep
To be honest
from the perspective of either the public
or a doctor
this might seem a bit counterintuitive
or against what we expect
Usually
we will talk about what kind of effects
might help with sleep
or how to address specific syndrome
like reducing heat if you have excessive heat
or tonifying if you have a deficiency
But what does any of this have to do with flavors
Let's start with the traditional view
Traditionally
insomnia is usually categorized as
either trouble falling asleep
waking up in the middle of the night
or waking up too early
For those who can’t fall asleep, we often think it's due to excess heat
So what flavors should we use
Bitterness
because it's good for clearing heat
And if you wake up too early in the morning
what should you add
Salty and sweet flavors
So, in the end
the medicine we use is the same
but the way we explain it
might make things seem more complicated
than they really are
We came up with terms like
'heat,' 'deficiency,' and 'depress'
to explain why
bitter and salty flavors
help with sleep
but honestly, it's not that complicated
Sleep is regulated by these
three specific flavors in relation to the heart
But if I don't understand
this concept of flavors
how might my approach to treating insomnia
differ from when I do understand it
Let’s put it this way
if different ways of thinking
lead to the same conclusion
it might seem like it doesn’t really matter whether you think about it or not
But that's actually an oversimplification
In practical situation
like finding a Traditional Chinese medicine
for tranquillization
you might wonder
if this herb is bitter
does it really have the effect
But what if I told you that
a specific mix of scents
could help treat insomnia
In that case
we first decide on the scent profile
and then
choose ingredients that fit the profile
This way, we have a lot more options to work with
This actually clears up a misconception
When I first started out
I used to think certain medications were effective for insomnia
but over time, they'd stop working
Then, I began to realize that sometimes
treating insomnia isn't just about using the obvious solutions
Instead, some treatments that initially seemed unrelated to insomnia
actually ended up
being more effective for the patient
So this concept
it truly explain
why medications that don't seem like
they'd help with insomnia
can be so effective
There's been a shortage of medicine lately
People are saying
the jujube seeds are a bit pricey
that we can’t afford it, is there another way around?
Jujube seeds help with tranquillization
so I tell them to use smoked plums instead
since they're both sour
If smoked plums aren't available
try using dogwood
The point is just go for something sour
Basically this recipe for treating insomnia
are just lacking the sour flavor
If you’re still having some doubt
about this concept
let me share something with you
Few days ago, I watched a YouTuber
It’s pretty interesting
Who’s a Michelin chef
cooking at home
with some really fancy ingredients
After tasting it
he said something
that really stuck with me
'It still doesn't seem sour enough.'
Someone asked him
if it was the first time he was making that dish
and he said yes, he had just come up with it on the spot
because those were the only ingredients left in his fridge
The takeaway is
a good chef
has a sense of flavor combinations in their mind
So, when they make a dish
for the first time
their first thought isn’t about adding more
or less of a specific ingredient
Instead, they think, what flavor is missing
and how do we adjust it to be a bit more sour
I believe a good Chinese medicine doctor
works in the same way
I watched that episode
where Chef A-Chen’s friend
was talking about
how her dish wasn't sour enough
She mentioned you can use citrus fruits
yogurt
or other sour ingredients
to adjust the flavor
that would add a different taste
So, all you have to do is
by using this framework
of using sour, bitter, sweet, spicy, and salty
we can really break free from the traditional limitations
we usually think of while using herbs or ingredients for health.
Yeah, he kind of blurred the line
between herbs and ingredients
Let's do a little experiment
We'll start by talking about
when you should use more of these three flavors
and I'll throw in some chef tips along the way.
For example, when it comes to our heart
there are basically two states
one is called “excess,"
and the other is "deficiency."
When we talk about excess
it means you have excessive internal heat
Besides insomnia
you might also experience things like
mouth sores
or acne
this is what we mean by excess
In this case
you should lean more towards bitter flavors
On the other hand
if you’re dealing with insomnia
along with symptoms like palpitations or a sense of unease
that means your heart isn’t strong enough
When do we feel palpitations?
For example
When we go for a run
and might notice that
your heart might be a bit weak
and you feel like you really do need a break
so palpitations is a classic condition of
deficiency
In this case, you should adjust your medication
to be a bit saltier
If that's the case
I might think about adding more bitterness to clear heart fire
or a bit more saltiness to strengthen the heart
Will be talking more about this in online courses
so please join us if you’re interesting
Then why don’t I just use bitter herbs instead
I could just use a single herb like Coptidis Rhizoma for bitterness
and a single herb like Jujube for sweetness
That will do
doesn’t it?
This touches on an important concept
When we talked about syndrome differentiation
we often used a kind of either-or thinking
just like binary opposition
It’s either yin or yang
black or white
zero or one
This kind of mindset makes us wonder
‘Am I experiencing excess in my heart or is it deficiency?’
But let me ask you
If I give you a brief overview
based on what we just talked about
excess in the heart might include symptoms like
heat, insomnia
and mouth sores
while deficiency could involve waking up early
and experiencing palpitations
Is it possible for a patient
to experience both of these at the same time?
Yeah, it’s pretty common for some people
to have two symptoms at once
This happens a lot
so not everything is black and white
Symptoms have a certain balance
and the same goes for
the scents used in medicine
I want to create a recipe
that the body likes
but not just throwing in something like
ice cream, because you love sweets
so I’ll just add in all the sweetness
If you overdo it with sweetness, it’s just too much
and I’m not a fan of that either
It seems like a Chinese medicine doctor
is kind of like interpreting what's going on
with your symptoms
Remember how we talked about
the left brain and right brain concept before
The right brain is about what your body needs
while the left brain is what your mind wants
It’s like the doctor is figuring out
what your body, or right brain
is craving
and then put together that specific flavor
It's not just about one particular flavor
being the ultimate solution
Yes
exactly
So the clinical approach
used to starts with your symptoms like insomnia
and then determines which herbs can help with sleep
and calming effects
It shifts from choosing specific medications
to assessing your current health condition and figuring out
what kinds of flavors your body needs
Flavors
To be precise, flavor combination
For example, with insomnia
it might be a combination of sour, salty, and bitter flavors
The key is to combine these flavors in specific ways
and use ingredients
that match these flavor profiles
So you’ll see that
when we first start cooking
we usually follow recipes carefully
measuring out grams of this
cutting how much of that
and figuring out just how much salt and sugar to add
The recipes I dread the most are the ones that say 'a pinch of salt' or 'a dash of sugar.'
Huh?
What does that even mean?
But actually
as an experienced chefs
they just taste as they go
Taste it and they know ‘It’s not sour enough
, need to add a bit of sweetness in this.’
same as experienced Chinese medicine doctors
while they take your pulse
and might think the treatment needs a bit more of a certain flavor
Our approach is based on solid evidence
There's a book called ‘Tang Ye Jing Fa’
What’s so special about this is that
the author of ‘Shang Han Lun,’ Zhang Zhongjing said that
his formulas
were all based on it
Here's the twist, the author of the 'Tang Ye Jing Fa,'
Yi Yin
wasn’t a doctor he was actually a chef
So, I believe that
the fundamental principles of Chinese medicine
are closely connected
to these flavors
Take my trip to Spain as an example
At that time
I had just finished Dr. Xiao's workshop
before heading there
Well my trip was sort of
a belly-belief journey
I was eating non-stop
and ended up with a stomach flu
At that time
my stomach felt really bloated
and uncomfortable
and I didn’t have much Chinese medicine
with me
So what did I do
I decided to try olive oil
You know how in Europe
there’s this trend of using olive oil for health
Well,
I had two types of olive oil with me
After trying them
I noticed that olive oil generally has a slightly sweet flavor
But, extra virgin olive oil
can also have a bit of a spicy kick
due to the polyphenols in it
I found that
the olive oil with that sweet taste upfront
and a spicy aftertaste
actually worked better for relieving my bloating
It made me think about what you said about the spleen
and the flavor profile of the spleen-earth element—
the sweet, pungent and bitter of it
If I want to reduce the excess spleen energy
like when there's too much food that's hard to digest
I actually need to increase the pungent flavors in my diet
A bit of kick from these flavors
along with some strong
spices
can really help my digestive system
Sweeter type of olive oil
can actually get a bit overwhelming when you eat it
That’s right
So in this episode
we want to show you
how to adjust flavors
based on your own situation
For example
if you try a herbal tea
that seems to help you sleep better,
but after drinking it
you end up with a sore mouth
and feel like
you have excess heat, you might wonder if you should stop drinking it
Well
if you think about what we just discussed
the balance between excess and deficiency in relation to
salty and bitter flavors
most herbal teas if you look closely
focus on these three tastes
So Dr. Xiao
I’ve got a general idea now
about the scent ratios
for insomnia
I just found a herbal tea with calming effect
online at random
I should mention this is totally random
believe it or not
so if it happens to be spot on
That’ll just be a coincidence
This is the info ChatGPT provided
We’re looking at a herbal tea
related to calming and sleep
Does it actually work?
Let’s see what’s in the ingredient
It contains chamomile
longan
rose
jasmine
and monk fruit
Can you imagine
what this would taste like
We specifically chose something that
doesn't have a strong medicinal taste
Longan, which we just talked about
is longan pulp
has a sweet and slightly salty flavor
As for other ingredients
things like floral and fruity ingredients
like monk fruit or flowers
they're generally more on the sour side
So, it's really
a combination of sour and salty flavors
Based on this
it definitely help soothe your mind
That’s for sure
The lesson here is
just as we mentioned
like a chef tasting their dish
one bite and you know how to adjust your flavors
But how you can apply this
on making herbal tea
If you find that
drinking it helps you sleep a bit better
but also makes your mouth sore
What does it means
it might mean the tea is too strong
leaning toward excessive heat
In that case
you should reduce the saltiness and increase the acidity
So, I'd really encourage you
to cut back on the longan
or even leave it out entirely
or just use a very small amount
You could also replace it with jujube
or other sour herbs
Right now, the only sour ingredients are monk fruit
and rose petals
You can even add something like
jujube seeds
It might be better to achieve that
calming effect
If you can't find jujube seeds
you could use schisandra instead
Or even
adding a bit of ume juice
which works well too
Basically, just add a bit more sourness
So what if
I add a bit of balsamic vinegar
Technically
theoretically it would work
but I really can’t picture
adding balsamic vinegar to your herbal tea
Like what?
What if
I add a bit of lemon
Of course
lemon zest or even citrus based
It can balance out
the salty flavor
and increase the acidic taste
This might make the tea less heating
and more soothing
By this you’ll not have excessive heat
which could potentially help you sleep better
On the other hand
if you drink it
and you do feel it’s easy to fall asleep
but somehow feel cold
and tired
even feeling off during the day
or experiencing palpitations
Here
I might think
Should I add something
warmer to balance it out?
But that’s a common misconception
A lot of people believe that
if their body tends to be cold
then they shouldn’t drink certain things
Patients often say this to me
but in reality
it might just be that the tea is too sour
and not salty enough
Remember we just mentioned
salty flavors works like fuel
that increase your internal heat
make it burn brighter
so you don't feel cold
So instead of
adding spicy herbs
you should lean more towards salty ones
Like add a bit more longan
If you use longan along with jujube
the overall effect of the herbs
will shift towards warming
and excess heat
It can help improve
your mood, energy
and sleep
Some people might think of
adding cinnamon
etc.
So what’ll happened if you use cinnamon
You need to know that
cinnamon is actually a spicy ingredient
not a salty one
When you added it
it might not be as effective
for calming the mind
Spicy flavors don’t really affect
the heart in terms of regulation
so we usually opt for a bit more salty herbs
just a bit more
This is the misconception that we talked about earlier
like I used to underestimate longan and jujube
but in reality
when used it wisely
they can sometimes be
even more effective
This shows that
if people rely only on
cold, hot, warmth, and coolness
they might think
they’ve balanced things out
but it might not actually achieve the intended therapeutic effect
I think I get the overall idea here
I would like to ask
you mentioned that jujube and longan are both considered “salty”
But the kind of "salty" you’re talking about
in Chinese medicine
seems a bit different
from what most people think of as salty
What does this means?
I think the confusion
comes from the fact that
in Chinese medicine
all foods and herbs
are categorized into five flavors: pungent, salty, sweet, sour, and bitter
So, there’s always
some sort of leaning or nuance
For instance
take salty flavor as example
In cooking
there's something called the Umami Flavor
For example, foods that come from the ocean
we’ll describe it as Umami
like clams
or lobster
are often said to have a Umami taste
But do they really taste salty?
In Chinese medicine
we classify them as salty
Now
let's talk about sweet flavors
We mentioned earlier that longan
and jujube have a sweet flavor
but there are other sweet flavors too
like yam
and Job's tears
Do these sweet flavors feel the same to you?
Do you think they taste the same?
It's sweet
but one has a salty undertone
while the other is purely sweet
maybe even a little sour and more mild
Based on this concept
you’ll see
you can gradually understand about this saltiness
by practice
For example
if we compare longan and jujube
and if I were to add a third one
this is just my opinion
maybe even a ripe mango could work
If you have a mango at home that’s overripe
you can add it to your herbal tea
Why
Because mangoes can increase
the body's internal heat
We all know that when your skin isn't in great condition
you shouldn't eat too much mango
because it can cause flare-ups
But when you eat longan, it can cause mouth sores
because it actually has a bit of a salty taste
Actually, it seems like
when we talk about 'salty' in ancient times it wasn't just about the taste of salt
It included a richer, umami-like flavor
something really intense
and fresh
This is what we called salty
And back then, salty foods were believed to nourish the heart but also increase internal heat
So, this is why
you might be advised not to eat salty foods
when you have skin inflammation
a cold
or any condition that's causing excessive heat
It's not about specific fruits
or whether something is too cold
but rather about
the saltiness and its effects
We've put together a chart here
that covers the different types of flavors
of some common ingredients we use
It's a basic guide to help you get started with
understanding these flavors
Think of it as a '1.0' version of how we use flavors to support the body
We'll be diving deeper into this chart
as we go along
Alright, so one last question for you, Dr. Xiao
When it comes to sleep
how can I apply the concept
What kind of dish
could a mom cook using those flavors to help her kid or husband
who's been stressed about exams and not sleeping well
Something that would invigorating heart
and improve their sleep
What we really want to bring to this episode is
showing you how to practically apply this theory
Not dreaming up
or making up a good herbal tea out of nothing
Try it out yourself
Think of something salty, sour, and bitter flavors
In cooking
it’ll probably be
bitter might be something like bitter melon
sour
could be pineapple
and for salty
you might use pickled pineapple
Pineapple with bitter melon soup—does that work?
Yes, you’ll find that
the recipe you randomly come up with
like pineapple with bitter melon soup
if you search online
you’ll definitely find it listed as something that clears heat and tranquilization
Trust me
and try it yourself
You can think of
any calming recipe in your mind
and then look it up online
You'll definitely find
it has calming effects and helps with heat-clearing and various other benefits
I often feel that
these effects are actually a result of Chinese medicine theories
It’s like how all ancient civilizations
are often said to have developed along the
Euphrates
and Tigris rivers
Our civilization
followed these two rivers as we developed
If traditional Chinese medicine were considered a civilization
its origins would be in flavors
The effectiveness of different ingredients
flows from these flavors
So now
we're giving you a glimpse into
a more wider
more higher perspective
With this
you'll get a clearer view of how everything fits together
Just now
I had an interesting thought
As you know, I really enjoy drinking coffee
I’m planning to invite
an amazing coffee roaster
who was the first Asian
to win the European Roasting Championship
We'll talk more about that later
So, drinking coffee
caffeine can cause insomnia, but
some people
including myself
find that drinking high-quality coffee
before bed actually helps them fall asleep easily
I feel like it’s the same concept
This is where we see
a different take between Western and traditional Chinese medicine
or just a gap
in understanding the world
if we only look at it from a material perspective
I can’t say for sure
because there's no clinical research to back this up
but from my observations
a lot of patients have told me that
when they drink good coffee
by that I mean coffee with certain characteristics flavor
That is usually purer
and more complex
It’s not just overwhelmingly bitter
instead, it might have floral
or fruity notes
and the flavor changes from the start to the finish
kind of like how perfume has different layers of scent
People say that after drinking these coffees
they actually feel relaxed
and even sleep better
From this perspective
if a combination of sour, bitter, and salty flavors
can help you sleep better
why can't coffee, which has these flavors
do the same?
From the standpoint of caffeine
coffee
is usually considered bad for sleep
However, if you look at it from a flavor perspective
this combination of tastes
might have the desired effect
Maybe we can try to
explain it this way
So let me break it down
When we talk about flavors like sour, bitter, and salty
salty as we mentioned
tends to have a rich, sweet aftertaste
I believe that a good coffee should have that
fresh, sweet aftertaste
along with a hint of bitterness
I’ve noticed that
the difference between good coffee and regular coffee is that
In terms of an antioxidant perspective
good coffee has enough polyphenols
and Chlorogenic acid
which are antioxidants that can actually help with sleep
This is how I used to understand it from a chemical perspective
But now we know that
Chlorogenic acid gives a sour taste
and polyphenols add a bit of bitterness
and good coffee has that salty touch
which together
create a perfect blend for soothing insomnia
Exactly
So, imagine if ancient people were tasting coffee
though they probably didn’t
but just imagine
They might not have been able to identify things like
Chlorogenic acid
but they might have noticed
the coffee's sour taste
and might have thought that this could be used to help with insomnia
So, if you find that coffee
doesn’t have that salty
and sweet aftertaste
it’s best to avoid drinking it after 3 PM
The caffeine in it
is likely to be a major cause
of insomnia
But it depends
if you're drinking coffee to stay awake, then that's one thing
But after hearing all this
it really feels like
Chinese medicine makes things seem very complex
Yes it has a lot of depth and knowledge
but there's this idea
that simplicity is key
it all boils down to something simple—
Chinese medicine in every bite
So, let's use this concept
and insomnia as a way
to give everyone a glimpse into the fundamental principles of Chinese medicine
how the five flavors can help balance the body
If you’re someone
who spends time in the kitchen
or brews herbal teas
we’d love for you to share
your experiences. How do you get creative with your blends
how do you tweak them
and how do you feel after?
Feel free to comment down below
to share with others
We’ll will check them out
Thanks for all the support
and inspiration
Together
we can bring more useful
and inspiring insight to this channel
Until next time
bye!